what's up guys bangbang lunch money time
Wednesday
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right I am here with the beautiful and
intelligent miss Polina mara Nova as you
can tell she has a checkerboard on her
jacket because she's been getting
smashed in chess so now she wants to
play checkers while I want us playing
checkers on playing chess okay calm
what's going on with Jett Walmart bought
it four years ago for three point three
billion dollars mark Laura they wanted
more klore who was the founder of
gangster diapers calm is what he did
previously right I think he sold like a
few companies for over billion mark lore
is a gangster at selling things on the
Internet that's basically what it comes
down to but now four years later Walmart
is shutting down Jett calm but the CEO
of Walmart said absolutely I would do
that all over again not only did we pick
up mark war we picked up fulfillment
centers a lot of expertise that ended up
paying off is Mark Steyn is it mark so
like the whole idea here as my guess is
if I'm Walmart one if Mark Laura stays
that's a win literally he's worth three
billion dollars by himself to is if they
got infrastructure I didn't know that
and then the third thing is they
probably learned a ton and are able to
take all the learnings from jet comm and
that link commerce effort and bring it
to Walmart calm and go ahead and do that
because I believe that mark or runs
Walmart comm he does he does alarm so my
guess is that like literally what
they're doing is they're quote-unquote
sunsetting or phasing out jet comm
there's gonna suck it into Walmart comm
and because and because of the deal all
Walmart is now attracting younger more
affluent people yeah and I you guys have
probably heard us say previously that
there are very very few companies in the
world that I've ever raised you know
hundreds of millions of dollars out of
the gate before they had a product ended
up being successful jet comm is one of
the only companies I know that did it
mark Laura raised hundreds of millions
of dollars and ended up selling for 3.31
Laura had like a
he wasn't just like a random dude they
picked up you don't know the diapers.com
story more this is why mark lures a
gangster he literally started selling
diapers on the internet I think I was
like 1-800 diapers com was there the
original web site and he eventually got
diapers calm and they would go to this
store you like drive around his local
area in New Jersey and he would buy
diapers and turn her out and then sell
them on the Internet at a loss in that
business I forget how long it took but
it was like in 12 months or 18 months
he's like a million dollars a month in
diaper sales and he had no
infrastructure no supply chain he was
simply just buying it at the store
selling it online pretty crazy
what's going on Magic Johnson so Magic
Johnson is teaming up with MBE capital
partners to offer a hundred million
dollars in loans to minority and women
owned companies hurt by stay-at-home
orders due to Coba 19 do we know what
the interest rate on the loans are I
don't I was actually trying to figure
that out so I'm always a little yeah I'm
always a little cautious here there's
two ways that this can go one first of
all there are a lot of people hurting
it's fantastic that they want to get
capital but you can take this one in two
ways the government for example is
giving out literally loans at 50 basis
points or one for 100 basis points 1
percent so they're very low-cost loans
if you now walk in and you say hey we're
gonna give loans to minority businesses
or women let businesses but at 12 or 15
percent Interest it's a little predatory
right and especially because you're
trying to do it under the guise of like
doing good if you're gonna offer high
interest loans like just offer high
interest loans don't target certain
groups well if somebody can find out
what the interest yeah and by the way
the other way could be is a low-cost
loan right and it's this really film
topic can I tell you a secret yes wait
why I just I hate them I just I don't
like my when I was in college and I was
seeing my loans off I was like hmm this
is how they try to screw me out of money
but but don't you think that it's better
to be the one giving the loan than
taking the long I guess but I feel I
would feel kind of slangy
why I don't know I would just give owns
without interest I just feel like here
here's like some money I
okay well we know who's not gonna be
managing money in this relationship not
a capitalist watch out do we have a
secret social okay but you have to get
if you take risk you should get a return
right yeah ah I can see the mental
wheels they're spinning
there's spinning real fast there's
company some steam coming out of that
head soon all right speaking of wheels
my man Joe Rogan bang bang struck a
hundred million if not more deal with
Spotify it's a licensing deal it's not
they did not acquire Joe Rogan but its
massive Joe Rogan is gonna go down as
one of the best businessmen of our
lifetime you want to know why a lot of
nope no I do not you've never heard me
say that on this show ever before nope
the reason is he did two things that
were incredibly intelligent first he
never raised money he owns 100% of the
company yes and to bill simmons sold the
ringer a podcast network to spotify he
sold the company everything Joe Rogan
didn't settle he's getting paid a
hundred million dollars in an exclusive
licensing deal but he still owns the
company he still owns I would love to
know how long of a time he sold it for
the licensing deal but this means that
in two years three years five years
drill Rogan can take his thing and go
somewhere else yeah my guess is that the
hundred mils per year oh really so
Howard Stern in 2004 signed a five-year
five hundred million dollar contract
Howard Stern the dude talk about sex in
2004 was getting paid a hundred mil a
year what's interesting is they he then
after that Sunday 12 year deal that ends
this year nobody knows the financial
numbers on that deal but it's estimated
that last year he made over ninety
million dollars so he's been getting
paid a hundred mil basically for what
fifteen to seventeen years now
the dude's worth over a billion dollars
easily and at the end of this year or
this year the contracts up and they're
trying to
negotiate it so my guess is that Rogen
basically walked in it was like hey if
you want me to be exclusive to your
platform Howard Stern was exclusives
serious he said hey it's gotta be 100
mil is minimum to go do can I say
something yes you can say whatever you
want it's your show now even though I
was a reporter covering venture capital
and startups for a few years I am I love
people who have businesses where they
own a hundred percent why I think it's I
think it's such a badass if you can
build the company into a massive
behemoth another example of a hundred
percent is Sarah Blake you can say that
thanks you love her a hundred she
founded it 20 years ago I love her
because she was she she was like
basically her philosophy is if you think
genuinely that getting some outside
capital can help propel your business
and crazy ways to do it but otherwise
it's just gonna make you less
disciplined and well the crazy part of
her story she started Spanx with $5,000
turn it into a billion-dollar bit now
it's before--the more than a billion
dollars she owns a hundred percent of it
and tell the story about when she met
her husband Jesse hits ler and what she
had to have a conversation with Jesse
it's law by the way has sold multiple
companies probably worth a couple
hundred mill he's rich like fu rich I'm
done rich but what is their big have to
do I was listening to this podcast
basically where she said when they met
they got engaged pretty quickly after
they met and then their wedding was
shortly thereafter so a few weeks before
the wedding she had a panic cuz she was
like oh my god I don't actually think he
knows how rich I am so she sat him down
at a restaurant was like listen I know
you think like spanks like it's footless
pantyhose you think it makes like a
couple million dollars um actually it
makes hundreds of millions of dollars
and I'm actually a billionaire according
to her and he started crying
so happy sweet what's he like a
gold-digger happy or like or was he
happy that like he was happy that she
was successful okay alright well goes
going back to Joe Rogan Joe Rogan so
owns all his [ __ ] got paid 100 mil by
Spotify hot take is this may actually be
a bad mood why so here's my logic is we
are on the precipice big word SAT with
what I say that's why just says
impressive peace now you must have heard
well get the wax out of your ears read
the internet and what's gonna happen
here there's gonna be an explosion of
audio content and if Joe Rogan goes
exclusive to Spotify what happens now is
you have to be on Spotify to listen to
Joe Rubens full episodes he actually may
miss out on a massive number of year of
growth in the next couple of years while
he's exclusive to Spotify
he can always go back to those platforms
but right now I bet you Joe Rogan last
year if I did over a billion views on
YouTube what's your favorite Joe Rogan
episode ever yeah that's really hard I'm
a big fan what no no you go first I like
the one with David Goggins look him up
David Goggin Zondra yeah David gagas is
pretty good I'll have to get back to you
on that I don't think I could pick a
favorite like there's so many good well
that's the Barney one no but Bernie
Sanders was I actually didn't like the
content I thought it was interesting
because I got a different perspective of
somebody who I thought I really really
didn't agree with
so it was like interesting but he's not
cited in the top 50 favorites um I'll
come back to you on that go let me think
a little bit alright what's going on
with clubhouse uh he see how I made him
think he never thinks this is good
clubhouse okay guys we're gonna there's
steam coming out of my ears
we're gonna get you in on a little
secret cuz I didn't know about this
until a few days ago apparently
everybody else knew but like I didn't
know so if I didn't know that means a
lot of you may not know um clubhouse
what the hell is clubhouse tell us well
I actually got to invite the clubhouse
yeah I'm getting my invite right now I
gotta invite the clubhouse I haven't
minutes I can't show you the URL but
look I got my invite right here alright
so clubhouse is basically like an audio
app yeah invite-only yeah I got the
invite
that was me flexing on the internet
flossing ah yes floss and you know that
was a big word on the Internet flossing
and the whole idea is you basically get
on the app and you can like drop into
conversation so let's say plan and I are
on we could be talking like this you can
drop in almost like you're like
listening to a conference call it to
some degree and then at some point you
can like raise your hand and get
selected to join the conversation or
kicked off so kind of think of it like a
audio Twitter but like embracing the
benefits of audio and of course this is
like gone viral within all of the tech
and venture capital community and then
andreessen horowitz just put in I think
was twelve million dollars at a hundred
million dollar valuation so literally
Pete who is the founder a pretty
well-known person him and Rohan started
this and they're probably I don't know
four or five months in and they really
got harmed our company in my
professional opinion they should have
named it eavesdrop
cuz you can like drop into different
conversations but each job has a
negative connotation clubhouses like
we're hanging it are you in the
clubhouse see you I gotta teach you
about being so you got to do a nerd
stuff I'll teach you to be cool isn't
listen to how he flexed so despite the
big names only about 1500 people mostly
with ties to prominent tech investors
had access to the chat I'd never know I
didn't even know that but now I got it
just means you're a nerd it doesn't you
don't need to be flexing no actually
somebody who's a dear friend of mine
texted me was like hey do you want to
invite I didn't know what it was that's
just said yes that's why haven't gotten
on I'll get on I'll report back don't
worry or plea no oh
what are you gonna get on with your
checkered suit going on okay Facebook
shop so shop till you drop
basically I've always wanted to say that
shop till you drop
do you hear the sound effects
shop till you drop I did do that go
ahead shop till you drop go ahead get
money get paid oh my god
so basically starting yesterday here
today yesterday you were able to browse
and buy products directly from a
business's Facebook page or Instagram
profile with the shop app that a lot of
people didn't realize Shopify is behind
the infrastructure I worked at Facebook
in 2014 on Facebook pages and we were
literally talking back then about
empowering this and six years later is
happening which is pretty crazy to show
to show know to show the discipline and
the long-term view of the teams there
because it's something that was like so
obvious to go do but because there's
tens of hundreds of millions of
businesses on Facebook like you can't
just you know snap your finger and then
turn on new features like you have to
very sequentially build out value make
sure people understand it like do all
this stuff and so it sounds like finally
now is the time they're doing it it's
cool but do you think that they should
have built up their own infrastructure
or do you like the fact that they're
using Shopify I cannot like the fact
that they're using Shopify think a lot
of people trust Shopify like Shopify
Facebook right now isn't the best in
terms of trust with the people so why
not do you trust Google or Facebook more
yeah is there an option that's like
neither good answer and then how about
this you know what I always confuse I
don't get confused very often but when I
do I always confuse Shopify and Spotify
with their public ticket like in the
public markets and I see people like
screenshot things I mean oh wait is that
Shopify or Spotify we're both the Red
Hawk so do you know that if I'm a
business and somebody buys from me on my
Facebook platform is Facebook gonna get
a cut what do you think they're in the
charity business they're not like you
they're not giving out loans for it with
no interest of course they're gonna get
paid money okay get money get paid guys
I'm thinking about getting
get money get paid hoodies for us not
for us for you guys okay master class
this is very mesmerizing
go ahead this is how he falls asleep at
night you just like looks at his master
class I can actually make my finger see
going down the stairs right there
master class raised a hundred million
dollars for celebrity fueled content if
you don't know master classes that
platform where celebrities teach well no
it's not always celebrities but mostly
celebrities teach skills to people I use
it this is not an ad but I just use it
simply good I do like it I think I'm
glad they are adding more people because
like I don't necessarily care about
Steph Curry teaching me how to play
basketball
I already know how to play basketball we
won't go there for the men at home that
was bait get me with that by the way if
anyone's gonna be teaching a master
class I should teach one finger I know
it's right off the screen huh so the
whole idea behind master class is
actually pretty smart it's a
subscription service and it's a math
equation right if you're investing this
late in the business or the cycle of
this business
you obviously know hey here's how much
it costs for us to require a user here's
how much the lifetime value is here's
what we think that each customer is
worth if that unit economics works and
they've got a path to continue to
acquire users then you invest money it's
not rocket science a subscription fee
for the user is a 180 for the 40 for the
year and I noticed I think they changed
their model because before I think you
were able to stop it I think you're able
to buy individual classes for like $90
or something and now they just made it
like 180 this is kind of like those guys
who sit outside at the car the car what
come to watch hey listen I'm doing this
for me this is for me I like the people
but I'm having fun too
speaking of me what's up with the
watermelon man watermelon man okay so
okay so these two where do you find the
weird minutes that's what everyone
really wants it so these two idiots
carved out watermelons put eyes on them
and tried to rob a convenience store and
yeah that's what happened so first of
all yeah there you go there's the photo
if I was a criminal I'd be the
watermelon man like you gotta ask
yourself when they're walking in looking
half like a watermelon half like an
alien are they are they laughing but are
they laughing to themselves they're like
yo this is ridiculous we may actually
get away with it you know what I was
thinking I was like it must know really
good you think so do you think
watermelon smells good yeah but it's
probably like really icky like imagine
getting watermelon in your hair you
probably don't have here and the juice
and the juice is flowing down your face
as you're alone in the community and
then what they just have the like the
the shell the shell yeah did you know
that's the best part to eat in a
watermelon Yeah right right at the edge
that's the best that's the most
nutritious part of the water gone free
facts for you here on lunch money okay
listen your finger dancing ability is
subpar we will work on it so II can we
talk about this though why do we think
they used a watermelon rather than a
mask right now if you're a criminal and
you want to wear a mask like you can
literally just like cover your whole
face and be like coronavirus the
customers amount of work that you have
to do to actually hollow out a
watermelon to stick it on your head it's
kind of crazy well and also like do you
cut a small hole and then like somehow
expand it put your head in and let it
close or do you cut the hole big enough
where then it just kind of sits but if
you fall off because there's no I think
one that's in front looks a little more
stable a little stable yeah
well listen if anybody's trying to rob
anything right now newsflash don't cuz
we live in a surveillance society
they'll definitely catch you Google is
watching yeah everyone's watching
do not encourage do not rob it anything
no I'm saying don't do it if I teach you
one
thing guys don't do drugs and don't rob
places like duh hey follow moms at home
you're welcome thank you just
short-circuiting um can I just say that
there was a comment that made my day
yesterday
oh the two-year-old yeah you want to
give the shout out
so reportedly there is a two-year-old
who watches the show every day
and when we start and I say bang bang
she runs around her house going bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang so I
don't know what your name is
two-year-old but from us at lunch money
to you happy happy birthday and bang
bang is it her birthday
no every day's your birthday when you're
- no problem by the way I'm over 30 and
I'm still having a birthday everyday -
so it we just finished right on time
alright guys that's it for lunch Monday
today well Wall Street's trying to get
rich the rest of us are trying to get
our lunch money right
go see your dance we'll see you guys